I think the first time I realized I
could actually speak and express
whatever was happening and talked to
people in a real way that's when I think
I became a warrior for my own shoes I
love that the first line in the book and
it was incorporated into the film it was
a dark and stormy night so when you read
that did you think this is my role yes I
never like it was just the universe and
it was just meant to be another theme in
the film is being a warrior and I think
a warrior means really owning standing
out is there a moment where you embraced
your uniqueness still working on it yeah
I think you have moments maybe where
you're like oh yeah I'm feeling okay in
this moment but you know I think and
that's that's the joy about the film is
that everybody goes through that yeah
that's what makes it so relatable
when did you first realize you were a
warrior was moving here sort of leaving
my kiss in Canon working on the office
is like an all-male all-white staff I
think that was when I really I had no
friends and to move out to LA and to do
that was when I felt like I was like
well if I just decide that I'm not
strong enough to do this then it's gonna
go away I think I did once I came to
Chicago and was no longer co-hosting
with anyone and I was really free to be
completely 100% myself on the air the
first time I produced a movie from very
start to finish was this movie called
wild Cheryl Strayed wrote the book and a
scared because I had never really
produced a movie like that from the
galley to actually get an on screen and
acted in it and get herself in the
wilderness and I was by myself it wasn't
a lot of dialogue and I'm a very chatty
person and I had to do it all just on my
face no makeup and but it was so
important to me because the book was so
important to me that it's a movie that
has a happy ending where the woman ends
up with no man no money no parents no
job and she's happy with herself
that was profound for me
[Music]
you